Do you remember when we had Professor
Jien on the show uh from Predictive
History and he gave us a breakdown of
PAX Judeica, also the United States
invading Iran and what would happen if
the United States invaded Iran. I want
to play for you some of those clips. I
just think it's a good time to revisit
some of this predictive history. He's
been spot on. First, I want to show you
this video. This was not from our show,
but this was from a different u from his
own show, Predictive History on YouTube.
This is what he said about um uh well
the these are his predictions here.
>> So in this class this semester I'm
making three big predictions right?
First is that Trump will win
uh in November. Second is that
um United States will go to war against
Iran. The third big predict big
prediction is that the United States
will lose this war which will forever
change the global order.
>> Okay. So, so far um two out of three of
those predictions that he gave obviously
before Trump was even elected was they
came true. So Trump was elected and now
here we are at war with Iran. And uh he
even said on our show that the United
States would would invade Iran. And I
believe he said that it would be before
April. But let's go ahead and watch what
he said when he was on this show about
the US invading Iran.
>> This is the new normal. Uh 2027 2027
will be even worse because that that's
when I think that United States will
actually launch invasion of Iran. So uh
2026 will be will be the great conflict
between China and America as they try to
reconcile the differences. And once you
reconcile the differences, this will
open up uh uh Iran for invasion because
great fear is that the United States
invades Iran at this point. Russia and
China will support Iran and and there's
a great possibility that the United
States will lose this war. Um there's no
way that Russia will abandon uh Iran,
but China can be negotiated away from uh
from Iran. And that's Trump's game plan
before he launches a full scale invasion
of Iran. Look, look, it's already been
settled there. There's already an
agreement that the United States will go
and invade Iran because if the United
States wants to maintain its imperial
hijgemony, it needs to control trade
access. It needs to control Iran. Um
because once it controls Iran, then
China is blockaded. The Bel initiative
is dead and and now the entire Russian
southern flank, okay, the the southern
bottom of Russia is open up is opened up
and and Russia could be outflanked. So
um Iran is crucial to the maintenance of
American hijgemony. The question that
the question now is when will this
happen and how will this happen? So I
think it will happen next year not this
year. Um and it need and Trump needs to
create this grand bargain with China
before he moves ahead.
>> Okay. So I do want to say something
because obviously we did invade. Well we
we haven't invaded. So, I think this is
important to remember when you say,
"Well, he said it would happen next
year, and look, we're at war we're with
Iran this year." He's specifically
talking about invasion. And he actually
does an entire show on this in uh on his
predictive predictive history channel.
And he talks about the US invading Iran
with ground troops. And he says this
happens, he believes, in March um or
February, March or April of 2027, he
says. So, I think that could be accurate
if the war continues on for a year and
there's no real um I mean, Trump has
even said today that he'd be willing to
send in troops and if there isn't any
real gains going on and if we're kind of
in this stalemate of this sort of air
and naval war, then it is very possible
that ground troops get sent in. And it's
also possible that the timeline is just
sped up. I mean, that's also possible
that um we didn't even have to wait a
year because Trump decided he wanted to
do it before the midterms or something.
>> Um Iran will also be a major flash point
in 2026 because um right now these
protests in Iran and we know exactly
what's going to happen because we see
>> Oh, maybe he's When did I have him on
the show? Maybe he is saying that um No,
I had him on in January. So maybe when
he says next year, do you think he means
next year?
in Libya and Syria. What's going to
happen is that Mossad is going to create
these insurgent groups in Iran on the
borderlands. They'll be protected by air
strikes and be financed by um by the
CIA. Uh you have these Mossad agents um
leading these groups and you'll have
slowly economic blockade of Iran. Uh you
have sabotage, infiltration in Iran.
You're you're going to hear a lot about
Iran because the Americans, the
Israelis, they'll try to create this in
this narrative that any day now. The
Mullas will flee to Moscow. Any day now,
the regime will collapse. Any day now,
the military will launch a coup d'eta
against Iran. Any day now, these Iranian
people will rise up and referral the
regime. And look, the reality is that
Iran is under tremendous pressure. And
so you'll have this infiltration, you'll
have these insurgent groups, you'll have
warfare going uh on in Iran. So you
you'll hear a lot about Iran in 2026.
Well, you may have seen the
conversations happening online lately.
Censorship is back and it's happening
everywhere. Platforms are controlling
narratives and pushing the stuff they
want us to see. We need to fight back.
Rumble is the only company that has
stood the test of time and deserves our
support. On one side, Rumble is
challenging big tech censorship, but now
on the other side, they've introduced
something that will give us protection
from the big banks shutting us off.
Banks can cancel our accounts and freeze
our cards. So, that's why they launched
Rumble Wallet. A wallet that no one can
cancel and a wallet that supporters can
use to instantly tip creators like
myself without any middleman taking the
cuts. With Rumble Wallet, you control
your money. Not a bank, not a
government, not a tech company, not even
Rumble can touch it. It's yours. Only
yours. Yours to protect your future and
family. You could buy and save digital
assets like Bitcoin and Tether Gold in
one place. Tether Gold is real gold on
the blockchain with ownership of
physical gold bars. It's not only a
wallet to buy and save, but also allows
you to support your favorite creators by
easily tipping them with the click of a
button. There will be no fees when you
tip my channel or others. And we
actually receive the tip instantly,
unlike other platforms where we have to
wait for some payouts. So support my
show and other creators by clicking the
tip button on my Rumble channel. It's
wallet.rumble.com. rumble.com.
Download Rumble Wallet today, open an
account, and step away from the big
banks for good.
What I think is interesting about this
is um you know, he's saying that rather
than using our own ground troops right
away, the US is going to use the US and
Israel are going to use these other like
MSAbacked or MSAD trained border groups.
and they're already talking about the
Kurds. I mean, that is something that
has been discussed as, you know,
activating the Kurdish population and
getting them to fight. Um, so that could
be the next phase. I mean, we start off
with the aerial, maybe we go into naval,
and then there could be these other
groups that they try to to fight, but
then ultimately US troops get sent in,
which is what Professor Jiang ultimately
predicts. Now, let's talk about what is
the point of all of this. And he says
this leads into Pax Judeica that
ultimately the United States loses the
war. The United States uh one and one of
the videos that I watched of his which
again I just really cannot recommend his
channel enough. Um, one of the videos he
talks about is how the US loses when it
comes to the troops on the ground. That
Iran is surrounded by mountains and you
can get the troops in, which is still
very difficult to do, but you have
multiple problems once you get the
troops in, which is why the United
States loses the ground war. And that
Iran is actually trying to get us into a
ground war. That is what they want
because they know if we get into their
country, we lose. And the reason is all
of these mountains, which means it's
difficult to get the troops in. Once you
get them in, you've got two problems.
you don't know how to resupply them
because it's very difficult to get over
all those mountains and and the bigger
issue is you can't get them out. The
troops are stuck. So he says that what
would happen is the troops end up stuck
in Iran and that the US threatens to
nuke Iran in order to get the troops
out. We basically say let our guys go or
we're going to nuke you.
And uh and ultimately at the end the
United States loses. This becomes a
giant failure for the US and we abandon
the Middle East and Israel ends up
inheriting all of our weaponry, all of
our all of the stuff that we have in the
Middle East because of course we're not
going to just uh well, we leave stuff
behind every time we abandon. But this
time we'll make sure the Israelis at
least get it because then we'll say,
"Well, our best allies and friends in
the Middle East, Lindsey Graham, um
they're the ones who are going to have
all that equipment, so we left it to our
greatest friends and allies, Israel."
Yeah. the greatest friends and allies
who got us into this war that just will
end up killing a ton of Americans uh
American soldiers but our greatest
friends and allies. So they end up with
all the equipment they become really
strong in the region. Then he says that
what happens is all of these big
companies end up building up these big
AI companies are they end up going into
Israel to build up in Israel because
they have fewer rules and regulations
there and and ends up creating Pax
Judeica and and Israel runs the world. I
hope he's wrong on that, but that is
what he says. Let's just go ahead and
have him explain Pax Judeica. This was
when he was on the show back in January.
Okay, let's talk about uh Pax Judeica.
So, you say right now we're in a Pax
Americana. A Pax America or Pax
Americana, which what's what's the right
term?
>> Yeah. Pax Americana.
>> Pax Americana. Yes.
>> And we're moving toward a Pax Judeica,
which is what exactly?
>> Okay. So um the year 1688 and this is
the glorious revolution. This is when um
the king of England is overthrown by the
nobility and William orange um who is
from the Dutch Republic he's installed
as the king and this is significant
because this creates the sovereignty of
parliament. So Parliament now is above
the king and what happens next is 1694
the creation of the Bank of England and
the Bank of England are these private
interests transnational capital. Um and
the Bank of England they they are
guaranteed by by Parliament. And so this
crazy idea that these private investors
can lend money to the bank of England
and and um if they make money they keep
their money but if they lose money then
the parliament the people um guaranteed
their losses. So it's socialized losses
privatized gains. Okay. So this becomes
the new model of global finance. Why
this happens? Why this happens is that
in Europe at this time the world is in
flames. the 30 years war, uh,
Protestants versus Catholics and all
these rich people, you know, the Dutch
Republic, the Hassuk Empire, uh, the
Catholic Church, they need to be able to
place their store their wealth in a more
safe place as the world burns. And the
safest place at this time is is of
course England because it's being
protected by the Royal Navy. And so, um,
all this capital shifts over to England
and it's stored in the Bank of England.
These private investors have control
over this capital, but it's guaranteed
by both the Royal Navy as well as by
Parliament. And this allows for the
creation of the British Empire. And it
it it's a fantastic model because um you
know, you fast forward 100 years and you
have the rise of Napoleon. And Napoleon
is this great conqueror conquers all of
Europe. But um Britain through the Bank
of England, he's able they're able to
find a seven wars against Napoleon until
Napoleon is finally defeated. This and
and then England becomes the most
dominant nation in the world. Okay.
Okay. So this became this creates tax
Britannica um Britannica and then you
know after World War I World War II this
creates tax Americana. Why? Because if
capital is able to move to England it's
also able to move to America right and
and and then you have creation of
Federal Reserve. But now that America is
burning where do you go now? Well you go
to Israel. Why? Because first of all
Israel has nuclear weapons. So um Israel
will be safe. Second of all the Middle
East has been destroyed right? Right.
Israel has no competitors. Um Iraq,
Libya, Syria, they've all been burned to
the ground. Iran is the last um on on
the list. And so once you burn Iran to
the ground, then Israel has complete
dominance over the Middle East and it
can be just rebuild the Middle East in a
new image. And this new image will be
one of AI surveillance. So ideas that
you have, right, AI, digital currency,
digital ID, you're going to face a lot
of stiff resistance in America because
Americans like their freedom. But hey,
the Middle East has been destroyed. You
can you can now replace your populations
with Filipinos, with Chinese, with
Indians. And then you you can insert
microchips into the bloodstreams and now
you have this perfect, you know,
surveillance state where everyone is
martyed. But not not only is everyone
monitored but their emotions are
constantly being calibrated, being
controlled by um by their surveillance
state. And so you basically have a slave
state. And then you introduce
transhumanism where you know all the
rich people in the world they can go to
Jerusalem and experience all this
transhumanist technology organ
transplants that allow them to live 150
years. Um so that's the very idea of pax
Juda Jud Judeica right capital needs to
move to more safe place which is Israel
but also these oligarchs they want to
achieve a transhumanist humanist vision
of the world and so um Israel has has
this technology but also they want to
create a c surveillance state in order
to maintain permanent control of the
world and that's pu judeica
>> great so basically what Trump is has
done let me just get this straight
is Trump has not only broken his promise
about no more Middle Eastern wars. We're
in a Middle Eastern war. He not only
broke his promise about no Epstein
files. I I mean getting the Epstein
files. We still don't have all of the
Epstein files, right? Which is highly
suspicious. And now we're at war with
Iran doing whatever it is Israel wants.
But now on top of it, the other thing
that people voted for Trump for was to
ensure that we didn't end up with that
new world order. You will own
everything. You will own nothing and you
will be happy. the surveillance state,
the big brothers, this the the uh you
know the cashless society. Everybody
thought Trump would be stopping all of
that to ensure you know stopping the
Claus Schwab World Economic Forum model
for the world, the social credit scores,
all of these things. And instead, Trump
has now accelerated that because it will
be controlled by the Israelis as they're
the ones who've developed all the AI.
They're the ones who've developed all
the surveillance and they're going to
instead control and develop and all of
these countries around the world will
pick it up and adopt it. Europe will
take it. China will, they're already
taking it. Countries around the world
will ensure that people are monitored,
surveiled, censored, silenced,
controlled. And Trump by ushering us
into this Iran war has just expedited
that. Isn't that lovely? Isn't that
lovely?
Um I want to play this video clip. This
is again this one's not from my show,
but he talks again about how Pax Judea
is created.
>> Israel fighting wars everywhere. Okay.
The main enemy right now is Iran.
In Europe, you have the Europeans about
to go to war with Russia. In Ukraine,
America right now is threatening to
attack Venezuela. Okay, South America.
You have 10% of the
um US Navy in the Caribbean and they're
about to attack Venezuela.
You have China
and Japan
at conflict. You have India here and you
have Africa. Okay. So, so what's going
to happen in the short term? Okay. Well,
what we know is that Europe is planning
to go to war with Russia.
Okay.
Okay. Europe is about to go to war with
Russia. Okay.
At the same time, you have a lot of
immigrants in Europe and this is this is
going to create civil wars in Europe.
Okay. Civil war. So you have both war
with Russia as well as civil war. So
Europe is kind of screwed. Okay.
America has the same situation where the
left right divide is so polarized that
eventually they'll go to war. If you
read the news, you may have heard about
the uh shootings at Brown University as
well as this MIT physicists who were
shot. Okay, so random violence will be
more and more common in the United
States. And you can argue it's all
deliberate because the idea is is this.
Let's just say you have a jar. You put
red ants in a jar and black ants in a in
a jar. They get along fine. But you take
a jar and you just shake it up and now
they're at war with each other. Okay,
that's what's happening where the left
and right, they really don't like each
other. They don't talk to each other and
they refuse to engage uh in debate with
each other, but they're going to they're
not going to fight each other unless
there's violence, in which case their
trouble mentality takes over and they
start killing each other. Okay? So,
we're going to expect civil war in the
United States.
Then you're going to have the Americans
start to attack Venezuela and possibly
other countries in South America. So,
America is in for a bad time. Okay.
China,
yeah, I mean, Japan and China and India,
they're all going to have conflicts with
each other. But also, what we should
expect is that America starts to embargo
China, meaning America uses its sea
power to block China from accessing
resources, more seas. And China imports
most of its oil
and a lot of its food. So if there's a
blockade of China, you can expect the
Chinese economy to really suffer. Okay.
All right. But and then what we can
expect to happen is America at some
point will go to war with Iran and this
will destroy both countries. Okay? Iran
will not lose this war, but it won't win
this war either because America is just
going to bomb the crap out of Iran. It's
going to send Iran back decades. But
America will lose this war. But this is
important because America loses war,
it's forced out of the Middle East. And
once it's forced out of the Middle East,
all its military assets goes to Israel,
which creates the Pax Judea. Does that
make sense, guys? That's the plan. Okay.
Okay, now you have Paxica
and what Paxa will do is start to
control the world because through chaos
and conflict, Pax Judea can make a lot
of money, right? Because Pax Judea,
what's going to happen is that you have
these technology companies like Google,
they're going to move over to Pak Judea
and build a global surveillance state.
You have civil wars, you need AI to
control people. If you're going to war
with Russia, you need weapons, okay? But
you also need financing as well. So, you
can expect a lot of banks to move to
Israel and it's possible Israel becomes
now the global reserve currency because
everyone is trading with Israel.
So that's how he says we end up with PAX
Judeica. That all of this is essentially
uh going to be the demise of the United
States. And there are people, not going
to lie, been seeing a lot of people
talking online about how they think
that's the end goal for Israel. That
Israel is ready wanting to overpower and
overtake the United States as the big as
the top dog. Basically, the little
brother has grown tall and the little
brother wants to be able to basically
beat up on the big brother. And they've
effectively over the last, I would say,
20 years been able to do that. It used
to be very obvious that the United
States was the big brother, Israel was
the little brother, but now uh growth
spurts happen and they grew and now
they're bigger than us. They are
controlling us. They've they've figured
out how to manipulate us. I wouldn't say
they're bigger than us yet, but they
certainly do know how. like we're the
older brother, but we're also the dumb
one. So, um they they they figured out
how to manipulate us in order to get us
to do what they want. But they're ready
to grow big and strong and just be the
bigger brother physically. Even though
they're the younger brother, they want
to be the bigger physical brother. And
when because they have that desire and
they don't want to be answering or
beholden or waiting for the United
States to help them out, they want to be
the ones controlling everything. They
want to bypass the United States
entirely. And now uh so people are
thinking that marching us into this war
with Iran wasn't just about Iran. It
wasn't just about hobbling and taking
Iran down, but it was also about taking
the United States down,
about lowering our place on the world
stage, replacing us with them. And that
is something to really truly think
about. I have to say, I hope that
Professor Jiang is wrong. I hope that
this that none of this pans out that his
predictive history maybe this time
history won't repeat itself that this
time um we will create a new history
that other nations in the future could
look back at and use their own
predictive game theory models on because
it is dismal to think that this is where
we're headed that our leaders were so
stupid all of these years after World
War II marching us into conflict after
conflict after conflict allowing the
military-industrial complex to grow
allowing the Israel lobby to be as
strong as it is to get us into another
war that is this time, according to
Professor Jiang, going to really be the
end of the US empire. I sure hope not,
but I'm also not going to hold my breath
um because things aren't looking so
good.
Thanks for watching this clip from the
full Kim Iverson show, which you can
catch Monday through Friday, 2:00 p.
p.m. Pacific, 5:00 PM Eastern, for free
at kimversonshow.com.
See you there.